Si vous avez regardé les vidéos précédentes,
Vous savez maintenant quoi faire si vous tombez sur des gens
qui ont des troubles de la conscience et de la respiration.
Mais si vous croisez quelqu'un qui fait une hémorragie, vous faites quoi ?
On va voir ça tout de suite !
Doug Ross, Cecilia Reyes, Gregory House, Michaela Quinn, Derek Shepherd, Elliot Reid,
Quel est leur secret pour être si sexy ?
Ils sauvent des vies !
Ça vous fait une bonne raison d'apprendre à sauver des vies !
L'autre raison, c'est qu'apprendre à sauver des vies ... ça peut sauver des vies !
C'est Dimanche, petit repas de famille, posés ;
Et soudain, Tonton René décide de découper le poulet
Le problème c'est qu'avant de passer à table ... bah, y'a eu l'apéro
Et l'apéro, Tonton René, il aime bien ça.
Résultat : Tonton René s'est "un peu" blessé !
Bon, sans aller jusque là, Tonton René s'est salement entaillé
Et ça saigne beaucoup.
Ça saigne tellement que ça s'arrête pas tout seul,
Et qu'il faut faire quelque chose pour éviter qu'il se vide de son sang
Parce qu'il en a que 5L et qu'avec 1L de moins ça met déjà sa vie en danger
Et si le sang est très rouge et qu'il gicle par saccades,
C'est que c'est une artère qui est touchée et ça peut aller très vite.
Je vous propose de voir ce qu'on peut faire, démonstrations à l'appui,
Avec notre mannequin de secourisme préféré.
Commencez par calmer Tonton René,
Allongez-le sur le sol, et demandez que quelqu'un prévienne les secours.
Demandez lui d'appuyer très fort sur sa plaie, même si ça fait mal,
Et s'il n'y arrive pas tout seul, faites-le à sa place mais en respectant quelques précautions :
Mettez des gants, ou un sac en plastique ou, au pire, un linge propre entre votre peau et la plaie de Tonton René.
Surélevez le membre qui saigne et maintenez la compression en attendant l'arrivée des secours.
Si vous avez besoin de lâcher un moment, vous pouvez tenter un pansement compressif.
Recouvrez complètement la plaie avec un linge,
Et entourez le tout avec une bande ou un morceau de tissu assez grand pour tout recouvrir,
et faire 2 fois le tour du membre.
Serrez bien fort et surveillez que l'hémorragie est bien stoppée
Si ce n'est pas le cas, reprenez la compression manuelle.
Oh, et quand on perd beaucoup de sang,
Ça donne soif. C'est possible que Tonton René réclame à boire.
Ne lui donnez rien
Même pas de l'eau.
[Maxime]: rholala, c'est long, je pourrais pas avoir juste un petit dijo là ?
[Julien] Juste un doigt ? Allez !
Si vous avez un doute, rappelez le 15, ils vous diront quoi faire en les attendant.
Dernière chose, dès que vous pouvez, lavez vous les mains.
Le sang c'est pas très propre.
Voilà ! DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo.
Abonnez-vous pour pas rater ça et en attendant:
Prenez soin de vous, prenez soin des autres et portez vous bien.